Back Up,
ladies and gentlemen.
Powerful Frankie the answer.
Edgar.
Thank you.
Who's got more heart
than this motherfucker?
How about nobody ever?
I mean,
you might have as much heart as him,
but that's all that's available as a
human is how it's all it's available.
There's no room for anything
else that you can get to the top.
If you get to the top.
He got Frankie Edgar Heart,
but you don't ever get to
more than Frankie Edgar Heart.
That level doesn't exist on the game,
but you Ryan favor man,
you ride favors.
Got Some fucking mad hard
to dude that Aldo fight.
That guy took bombs from all the leg
kick after leg kick after leg kick,
boom,
boom.
Made it five rounds after it's over.
His leg swells up like more than
twice the size of the other leg.
He took all these Twitter photos.
Yeah,
it was terrifying.
Man
is a Gamer too.
Everybody who trains with
them says he's better in the,
in the cage and he is in training.
Uh,
he's getting this fuck.
He's gaming as fuck
and he's an animal man.
We ride favors and animal.
But I was so impressed
with Frankie against cub.
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
he's so relentless.
I mean,
he would not stop,
just wouldn't stop and you could see cub,
but there was a certain point in
the fight where he was just like,
fuck.
Like,
what is this guy made out of?
He just doesn't get tired.
It doesn't get tired.
Cardio for days.
Nobody works harder and unstoppable heart.
Yeah.
You watched those gray Maynard fights.
Did he get hit with balls
of the best fights ever?
Oh my God.
The two first rounds of the,
uh,
the two second fights,
the first fight was a loss,
you know,
so it was like he lost a decision,
but that was like early,
early back in the day.
But the second two fights,
man,
we're just fucking wars.
They were so crazy.
Right.
That's what they,
they fought three times,
right?
Yeah.
Mainers.
There've been the same right after those.
No.
Yeah,
he's,
well,
he's definitely taken
some serious punishment.
He got stopped in his last fight,
right?
Yes.
Who stopped him?
Oh,
who do you mean your fight?
I'll pull it up.
This is a smart move by the UFC because
Frankie was just kind of chilling,
sitting on the shelf until Al Mcgregor.
Now he's got to fight to keep
them fresh while it's good too,
because it's not even in the
weight class that exists.
Normally competes.
Yeah.
So it's kind of,
or what happens?
He still has that fight available.
[inaudible] well,
they offered him a fight
against Tj and he's like,
nope,
not happening dude.
He says he's open for it though.
Is He?
But he didn't take it.
That's a tough match cause he's
not faster than Tj for sure.
How was he open to it
if he didn't take it?
He did an interview saying he's
not shutting the door on it.
Like he's open to it after this.
But he said,
oh,
after this he said no to
a title fight at the time.
Yeah.
But I guess he said he's open to it.
That's what I read in an interview.
I'm going to happen.
I wonder what happened.
What changed?
So Alexander Yakka view is the,
uh,
the guy that,
be stopped him and stopped
him in his last fight.
That it's tough to watch.
Ross Pearson stopped him before that.
Okay.
Actually it looks like it was
decision Yaka Yaka view is a decision.
Bras Pearson stopped him.
Sorry.
Oh,
that was in the second round.
Nate Diaz stopped him in the first round.
The Nate Diaz one was bad.
And at Tj Maxx one is the cage.
Yeah,
the TJ grant one was bad to elbow.
Yeah.
So he lost badly twice in a row.
T J K Odom and the first round
Nate k in the first round,
then Ross Pearson,
Klm and the second amount,
so three ferocious knockout
losses in a row to gray Maynard.
It's tough to see.
Right.
And then he law.
Yeah,
it's very,
he's a nice guy too.
I really like gray.
And then the F,
this is the last fight he lost by
decision to a guy that you know,
we never heard of before.
And uh,
he's,
I mean,
not that the guy wasn't a good fighter,
I'm sure,
but me,
you think about he was
fighting for the title,
fought for the title twice,
went to a draw with Frankie.
I mean,
they had incredible,
incredible fight.
But then the battery got drained,
man.
Okay.
Lights cold black.
Frankie Edgar's about to step out.
Okay.
Oh Shit.
Here we go.
Biggie,
boom,
boom.
Every comes charging.
Ryan Getting Ready.
His coach behind a man,
Mark Henry is a fucking ridiculous coach.
Good,
Huh?
Dude lit.
It's tough to hear it,
but you can hear him yelling out.
They switch up their signals every time.
They have a whole language for each camp.
Front combinations.
You'll see.
I'll nervous the coaches and he's sweating
profusely because he's yelling out
was in Frankie listens
like a fucking video game.
It's insane.
Wow.
That's cool.
For wins by knock off four by submission.
Three fight win streak.
V Bj Penn three times
Jesus fucking Christ.
Did he beat Bj Penn three times?
How crazy is that?
And the last one was just a demolition.
The last one was hard to watch.
Remember his fights with the Hendo?
Yeah,
those were good too,
man.
They were great.
Yeah,
and he's so undersized
compared to Henderson.
I mean Benson's a big one.
55 are and Frankie makes
one 45 pretty easy.
I like Benson at one 70 man.
He looked great against Dash.
I agree.
And I love how he's willing
to fight other people.
He's like,
you know,
I'll fight anybody.
What we was trying to fight Tyron Woodley,
he was calling Woodlea by well at least
trying to get that Johnny Hendricks
fight.
Hmm.
Yeah.
It's very interesting man.
Very interesting and no,
don't have a fight,
right?
I don't think he's thing right now
whenever say you say Hindo though.
I think Dan,
my bat confuse the shit out of me.
So there we go.
Number two and number three.
Well three at Bantam,
Uriah
and number two at featherweight.
Frankie,
the motherfucking answer Edgar reach
is about the same and the same height.
Yep.
Super Five.
Anything else?
Virtually identical.
It's crazy that he's 36 cause to me I
was 36 and Uriah Faber when I was working
for the UFC,
he was like the kid that was
2123 and now and even 36 pack.
Then you were like 30 when when you
were working for the key and the cage.
Now I'm talking about
when I worked for the UFC,
always worked for the UFC five 36 saw
when you first saw him fight those king of
the cage.
Right.
Cause I remember you were
telling me about him.
He bought in the WEC Hosanna what it was.
He found king in the cage too.
Did he?
Yeah.
He can king of the cage once.
And then he went to WC and that's right.
I am so curious about this fight.
He fought and Abu Dhabi has a blue belt.
He wrestled his whole life,
but he was a blue belt when he fought uh,
uh,
battling bean from American top team.
That was the first time I saw him.
Powerful.
Justin Buchholz shout out.
Yeah,
he's right there.
Yeah.
I'm really curious to
see how this plays out.
Predictions.
Frankie decision,
right.
All the way from three.
You guys bet on it.
Double or not.
Then
it's going to have to double on you.
We have APP to get you later.
Yeah.
We have to get half of it,
bro.
You're night having a half later.
They're not getting that.
You think?
I think Frankie wins three to two.
That would suck.
Let me close by.
Imagine the means if you lose.
Oh I know I'm gonna go.
It's gonna be tough to beat
that Bruce Jenner one though.
So
it was pretty,
God damn funny is I Instagram
15 seconds of that interview.
The part where she
asked him if he was gay,
are you gay?
Cause please know I'm not gay.
So that was hysterical.
So is the vocal,
he's like,
his eyes are fluttering and twitching
all these Panama hives and he's like,
no.
I'm like,
I only,
I've only been with women even
though it was so believable.
Would have something like that.
Like if you're transgender,
they immediately ignore all the other
ridiculous aspects of your behavior.
Like the fact that you fucking killed
somebody a couple of weeks ago by pushing
their fucking car in oncoming traffic
in a Humvee weren't paying attention.
Yeah.
I mean that some talks about poor
lady and they said he was dialed.
No,
he wasn't texting.
Sure wasn't paying attention though.
He wasn't paying attention
when he's driving.
Was it after or before?
Was before.
Before he came out.
Maybe this is just a big distraction.
No,
no.
He was already transitioning.
He's been taking hormones forever.
Here it goes.
But if it's also the fact that he's living
with attention whores his whole life,
I mean it's like he lives
in a ridiculous household.
I mean all these things come into account,
but he was the greatest
athlete of all time.
No,
no,
he's definitely,
no.
When you win,
when you win the gold
medal in the decathlon,
you know why you are no real
athletes were competing in that shit.
Go.
Is that the point?
Michael Jordan was not in
the fucking decathlon too.
Any black guys compete?
Kathlen okay,
here we go.
Here we go.
Here he was the greatest shut up.
Okay.
How's this play out inside leg kick by?
By Friday you got hit in the sack.
Come on,
come on.
Oh,
that would be nice,
I think.
I think you're right.
It has the power advantage.
Would you agree?
A hundred so Eddie,
you're,
you're free.
You're right here,
right?
You know what?
You taking your Ryan,
I,
I forget the Bat.
Who's the bet?
Ooh,
I got your eye on this one.
This is the bed double or nothing.
Eddie Bravo has your,
I got Frankie.
I can't believe you made them take
your ride a double or nothing.
Even though you were,
you were very strong coming into this.
Is it me or does Frankie Edgar's like
way bigger than your Rocky's big?
Well there's the same height.
It looks bigger.
I think your eyelids thicker.
Yeah,
he's thick.
I guess it's the camera angle.
It's also way Tanner.
It's interesting like they're moving
like this is a five round fight.
Like Frankie's like nice and paste slowly.
Lot a lot of footwork and movement
but nothing crazy as far as output.
It's going to be a really close fight man.
It's interesting seeing fracking
not have a speed advantage.
No,
I agree.
The rice fastest fuck man.
And then one 45 you know he's used
to fighting those one 30 fibers.
I W I think I like the fact that
it doesn't have to cut as much.
Wait for this fight to again at 36
it's probably he goes hard and smart.
Like I said,
I think you're right.
Has a power advantage in that he comes
off of weigh ins and has a picnic on the
ground like immediately does.
It does.
Yeah.
He's soup eating salmon off
the fucking spinning back.
Kick [inaudible] tell you what your
eyes are smart as far as business wise.
It goes there.
He's smart guy.
Yeah.
Well he owns a ton of businesses.
Chino in Sacramento in cars homes.
He's got a casino.
You have like part of a casino.
He torque.
He sold.
He sold a other companies.
A case Swiss.
Hey,
tell you what man.
Torque is a fucking great company.
They make really good gloves,
man.
There their boxing gloves or
my favorite boxing gloves ever.
Really for working out.
They made fight catch.
No,
they made shirts.
Dude,
when next time you over my place,
I'll give you a pair of gloves.
He gave me a few parents and
they're really fucking good man.
They're super comfortable.
Like they're the most comfortable
a bad gloves I've ever used him.
Okay.
Then you guys just always
connected with the right people.
A smart,
yeah,
we'll torque is a real good one.
They,
they make outstanding equipment.
They were great.
Hand wraps,
great.
Everything his other company was for.
Oh,
that didn't land
as Duane Ludwig working
with him for this fight.
You're I in Dwayne.
Don't see to,
these weren't wearing masks and Martin.
Ooh,
rank you with the take down.
If this is going to be a long fight,
it's going to be close.
This one's going down.
The judges that he,
this is going to judge.
You better not fuck me.
I swear to God,
man.
I'm going to freak out.
Freak out.
They're just me.
Just memes and $1,800.
It's weird.
You see these like these
logos all over people.
Shorts is the last time
you going to see this.
They got another month of
this going to mess them.
Me Too.
Some companies are like high Bussa man.
I mean they've been around
a long ass fucking time.
They're all just going
to go to Bella Torque,
right?
Don't you think they want
to be in this business?
This should go over to bell toy.
I mean they're already there and Bella
[inaudible] it's just not anybody watched
Beltre last night I did.
Who won the Kendall girl fight.
Kendall loss.
He got beat up man.
Bay To do,
didn't meet Wade.
Right.
So the,
the stripped him of his title.
Kendell got finished
yet round third round.
Wow.
Was it a five or four still
cy fourth round by round.
Five rounder.
Yeah.
Can he just kept taking
Kendall down over and over?
He's a big fucker.
I heard he's muscular.
He get ate up in the UFC though.
Good low,
good Frankie going high with the kicks.
I was really rooting for Kendall.
He's a good dude.
Great Guy.
Great dark jokes.
Yeah,
he's been around a long time.
Really has,
he had a lot more experience
than that guide foot.
I was super Antwon when,
whenever glories on,
on spike up.
Super into Oh yeah.
You see those heavyweights?
Paul?
I'm a big fan of Laura Dude.
Gloria's it shit.
I don't miss them.
Okay.
Yeah.
Niki holes can just one of my
favorite fighters for sure.
In any sport.
Yeah.
You fall on that last one,
right?
Oh,
did you see the arts 11 Simon
Marcus fight went to a draw.
That's fucking amazing career.
Uh,
do you see those heavyweights?
No.
There's no girl in glory,
but there's no famous girl fights.
More time Ronda Rousey kickboxing.
It would be cyborg seeing it.
Dom beat Cyborg.
Who's that?
Italian client.
Tiffany time bomb.
She's a beast man.
Tiffany time.
Yeah.
Know her last name but she's,
she's easy on the eyes and she,
she's a beast.
Yeah.
There's some pretty girls
that fight Moyie Thai,
but it's um,
it just doesn't have the eyes that
grappling that Gnarly's up your face.
I'm curious to think.
Elbows and the arms.
So good for him either.
Yeah.
Moitai true.
I'm curious just to see,
to hear your critique of Kathy long
striking and how she moves and all that.
Cause I never really paid attention.
Oh,
she's bad ass.
She's very high light rail
man like maybe a year ago.
And I work with her.
We,
we train at the same gym,
but I just never followed
women's kickboxing.
I knew she was famous.
I just never seen any of her matches.
And One night I put on a highlight reel.
Kathy law,
I'm on familiar.
Holy Fuck Dude.
Pull by law.
She was Kathy Long,
Howard's role dynamic and just
so full of fire chief from walks,
whoring walks or sheriffs
like she comes out.
Ah,
fucking on fire.
She got mad at that round two.
So,
uh,
who won the first round?
Frankie,
you think so?
Yeah.
Down that takedown.
He was barely a take down.
Buddy can kick to the
body when it's this close.
Those takedowns and cage
presence and the pressure.
When's your rounds?
Oh Frankie.
Right the knee.
Oh,
your wire.
Rather with a knee.
You ride with a kick to the body and
you ride with a kick to the knee.
I think I said Frankie.
Frankie barely won that.
First of all in favor.
Yeah.
If you're Ryan can make this
more of a kicking contest.
That's not like Frankie strong suit.
Oh,
but look at that.
Frankie throws a spinning back.
Pays for it though.
Oh,
we got out of it.
Goddamn is quick.
It's nose is bleeding.
I think it's always bleeding.
If he sneezes and starts bleeding,
that's like me,
man.
Wow.
It's just normal.
You know,
you get punched in the face all the time.
Mine just dry enough to add no surgery.
I blow my nose blood everywhere.
When you had a nurse,
no surgery,
and you had your,
uh,
your pipes opened up,
did you blow some insane
boogers out of that?
That was awesome.
Oh my God.
I felt the best thing in the world.
I took photos of them and
I put them on Instagram.
I almost made Thompson Mura throw up
and sounds terrible in the airport.
Oh,
it wasn't Instagram.
I don't think back then it was Twitter,
but I almost made whoa
head kicked by Frankie.
I almost made Thompson gonna throw up,
so I showed it to him.
Anyway,
that's a new Frankie Edgar man.
He's still in some
serious a kung fu kicks.
Yeah,
he's throwing some cakes.
I like that.
That's that Mark Henry and Phil nurse,
man.
I would blow some boogers that
were bigger than a quarter.
Like I couldn't,
didn't sell big data.
It's crazy ones.
And they were bloody and it
was like aliens when they,
when they took the
things out of your nose.
Right.
Like how many stitches?
It's the best feeling in the world.
Yeah.
Because I had plastic splints in
there for like two little stitches.
It made my nose wider than
the actual space open.
The dude who did it,
he was a wizard.
He retired,
but he knew his shit.
He cut out all the tr,
I think they're called turbinates
the inside of like the,
the bump,
the bone bump,
cut those down and then like cut out all
the scar tissue at a ton of scar tissue
and put these fucking tubes in there.
And then splints,
he's plastic splints.
The stitch it up and when it was over,
like my nose is wider,
like all this shit.
Like he like opened it up like nine,
change the shape.
You break that down.
Oh my God.
It's amazing.
My doctor sucked.
I don't breathe.
Great man.
Well you still get punched in the face.
I haven't been in the face tat much since
the surgery.
Uh,
the trash brown upper cut didn't help.
That's life though,
Dude.
For most of my life.
I couldn't breathe out of my nose.
Oh,
Frankie.
With an overhand right.
That was very nice.
Yeah.
What you call a mouth breather.
Look at this.
You get that?
Say,
hey,
that's a nose,
I'm jealous right now.
Have to honk on your belly.
Breathing efficient.
I love it.
I'm so happy with the surgery.
I didn't even bother that much and
I got two nostrils that are totally
different.
They're all fucked up inside.
You like the ones really like
the sliver and one's a whole.
Yeah,
I had three quarters blockage on one side
and almost a hundred percent blockage
on the other side.
Yeah,
my nose was useless at
a quarter of a nostril.
And that's it.
You don't having where they,
where they go in with the drill and just
kinda get it out of like all the shit.
Cause I used to,
I used to not addicted,
but I'd use it every damn day.
Sprint.
Yes.
I'd use African like clogged everything
man was addicted to that shit too.
You know?
I'll just do it every loosens you up.
Joey Diaz is addicted to it.
He was joking around about it on stage.
It's horrible for a man.
It's like when I did coke
I can fucking breathe.
Perfect.
It was,
now I'm addicted is fucking Afrin.
Can't breathe.
Yeah.
That African stuff,
I don't know.
I'm going to stand up.
Makes the veins smaller so then you
nose doesn't work as efficiently.
Yeah.
When you get addicted to it,
when you don't have it,
it literally will make
your nose the inside of it.
Swell.
Yup.
It's just so crazy.
So I had to go in,
they had like this little
drill and just caved out.
Polls.
Oh yeah,
like co quarter,
right,
where they taught cauterized.
Yes.
That's what they were doing.
It was nice.
Did it help?
Helia and then he got
punched in the nose again.
Back to square one.
Fuck.
So many fighters talk with
like nasal Uriah talks,
nasal.
Do I sound nasally a little bit.
I can't stand when I listen to myself.
Talk to see who's the most nasally.
Vandelay was used to be,
but then he changed his
nose to mean van got a good,
a nice soft side.
You got a good family.
So it's like face off Nicolas cage style.
You will see,
it's like a little article.
That is how he sounds.
I supposed to do a podcast
with him hitting nine full,
showed up two hours late.
Two hours late.
It's very good.
Got To food.
He was two hours late and left.
Really sent me text.
Sorry.
Cool man.
Okay,
thanks bro.
Is this,
oh,
that vendor,
they Silva.
He was late to two hours to wise to what?
Applying pursuit in Brazil.
My friend in Brazil,
there's is no time.
Nah.
For real though.
He changed his entire face.
Face off style.
I'm thinking about doing that.
I wouldn't mind a new
microscopic Kathy long.
Who?
The highlight reel.
Yeah,
check out.
Wait,
is she old school?
Oh yeah.
I'm talking about right now.
No,
no,
but she actually is 50 years
old and wants to fight.
She's in great shape.
She looks good.
She's in great shape still,
man.
She's the best female
fighter I've ever seen.
Says Chuck Norris.
Chuck cut through all this shit and you
had some actual fighting holds black
belts in three styles.
Her and Brian Cowen and she'd
always have her hair up.
She is bad ass though.
Ooh,
look at that girl.
She's fighting.
It looked like my mom.
Okay,
boom bitch.
There's some high level shit.
This is like in the eighties dude.
Yeah,
it was a PKA karate days.
Okay,
here we go.
Polls.
Come on.
Don't show me that.
Her fights,
man.
She's good.
My mom,
my mom,
my mom would fuck her up.
Come on.
Put some on her son.
It's so funny.
His fight as good,
super close man.
These fucking ground,
but I did not cost me 18 hundo.
You imagine Uriah pulls it off
if he wins the next three rounds.
Well that is tough.
That last round is a toss up,
right?
Well if Uriah wins three out of five,
that's all he has to do.
That's what I think.
Slow three.
Oh,
who the fuck knows man?
Who the fuck knows there and around three?
Yeah.
Edgar is probably going
to get the decision.
This is a weird fight for Frankie to man,
right?
You can see rise not even ranked at one
45 he comes back to one 45 navy beats
Edgar.
He's right in the mix.
It's about your legacy though.
Ooh,
good I to hand.
It's about your legacy though.
You know,
beating a guy like your eye,
the super fights.
A split.
Like what's left for you,
Ryan?
Frankie to do.
Yeah.
Title should be nice.
They both been there.
They've both been champs.
Right?
You know what's crazy here?
WC was,
but he didn't know.
It's crazy seeing this fight man.
Is that like thinking like man,
your Riaa almost could've fought BJ Penn.
That would have been saying
throws a wheel kick that
Uriah fighting against Bj
Penn would have been insane.
How cool is super fights though with
with these amazing legacy of these guys?
This is what it's about.
Yeah.
Like I don't want to see Frankie
fights on his weight class.
I don't want to see your,
I fight someone.
They've been there.
They've done that.
I think this is your eyes weight class.
What would be your all kind of look
at that old liver for the canteen.
Nope.
No Man.
Frankie got out.
Shit.
You don't think Frankie trail
piss out of that every damn dead,
but still impressive nonetheless
hard.
Keep them down.
Yeah.
Right back up.
It counts though.
Those count the judges check one for
the Frankie check one for big brown.
Sorry Eddie.
You could see how and see
what this heavy super fight.
Jon Jones rushed cane.
Yeah,
I think so too.
I'm in John Jones or said Weidman.
Come on son.
Oh,
I like that.
I must do small.
How dare you.
Are you serious?
How dare you Jon Jones came.
I was asking square garden.
Want to see that too,
but I just,
I don't know if king can
get through a training camp.
You know somebody who is
like putting this out there.
They were like,
you really think about what Cain did as
far as like cane make no mistake about
it.
The baddest motherfucker on the
planet in the heavyweight division,
the heavyweight division,
but the guys kind of like all of his
injuries have kind of left that whole
division in turmoil.
It's like he's only fought a few times
and she's only defend title 19 months or
some shit.
Yeah,
the,
the heavyweight division's wide open.
I,
it'd be nice to CBRE doom when I think,
I think it'd be better for the
sport for dooms a character.
He speaks well.
He speaks Portuguese,
speaks English,
she can speak Spanish.
Flu.
He's a funny guy.
He's on TV.
He's skillful as fuck to fuck Uriah
looking for the year teen again.
Canes like a robot.
All he wants to do is
wrestle and not talk.
Wants to do this for us all and not talk.
That doesn't work well when you're
trying to make money in this game.
You know what I'm saying?
Man,
Frankie heavyweight champ,
son,
you ain't gonna be no.
You Know Muhammad Ali shirts like k.
You know what I'm saying?
Keynesian going have that.
Never know I,
it's just a matter of whether
or not he can stay healthy.
Frankie said,
yeah,
we can,
man.
We're seeing how great he is
right now is another hens.
Oh Guy Man and Ricardo Almeida.
He's shown that cub,
Swanson,
relentless,
and it's now Ooh,
better get up.
Side slipped.
I'll tell you what's a
dope ass super fight.
I mean,
yeah,
it's a little early,
but I'm just saying,
hear me out.
Connor Pedis.
That would be interesting.
Cool fight right?
Pat is going to be out for almost a year.
I saw batty fucked his arm up.
I liked left Tuck,
man.
I like medicine a lot.
Yeah,
I do too.
Pedis got a new girls smoke
show pays to be the champ.
Man Pays championing more.
Well,
you know what I'm saying though.
I hear you.
I still has that bed.
His house,
docent belt.
She walks in.
She's seen that belts on.
Well you got think don't let me get
them better when he was at pitch.
Being here right now over my shoulder.
You walk through my house.
It just be on a straight fucking display.
Just with a highlight tape of my
entire career as the belt spins
just himself.
He used to wear it.
The clubs.
That was always the joke.
I,
Tim Silvia was to show up at
a bar with fucking belt on.
I'd do the same shit.
Ah,
dos Anjos man.
Holy Shit.
Is that guy good?
Huh?
Yeah,
I fell.
Dos Anjos versus pedes
was an eye opening fight.
What's next for Dose Angeles?
I don't,
does he have anything?
No.
Um,
he's injured.
They be cowboy.
Maybe mean cowboy.
You do.
If he batters Mech Dessie
that she wanted 100%.
Well I think,
and if he does give them a title shot,
what's that?
Seven in a row now you know who's fucking
flourishing of this Reebok deal is
cowboy.
He's like,
Damn,
I fight 12 times a year.
I'm about to get paid.
So right
Dj like that deal too.
I talked to him about it.
Worked out for him.
Works for some people.
Tim didn't like it very much.
Yeah.
I think Tim summit's Great Hymn
was only getting 2,500 bucks.
Yeah.
So this is an interesting fight.
Head into this fourth round.
Thank you.
Thought Frank Frankie's
up at least two to one.
You think so?
Yes.
These judges though,
man,
it makes me nervous.
Eddie,
you're super quiet over there.
You piss.
We made this bet.
Are you guys,
I tell you what,
I'll give her the money right now.
It doesn't look good.
That look fine.
Yeah,
it did.
Okay.
Did we go wrong bro?
How about that?
Bet with are not the bet.
But the matchup with Machida and your boy,
Yo Romero.
That's a fine,
it's interesting.
It's very interesting.
You all were marrow though.
He keeps getting hurt,
right?
Yeah,
he gets hurt too.
He's not young and all that
wrestling is in catch up.
He's 37 he had a significant neck surgery.
Like when he gets on the scale,
he's got a big scar on
the back of his head.
Like a where's back of his neck rather
like where they get the discs fused.
I Dunno if he had disectomy or I
don't know where he got it done.
Merrick or Cuba.
But there's that.
And then there's the last fight with
Jacques Rey that he had to pull out of.
Ooh,
that's a good fight too,
man.
That was a great fight.
But him Rockhold gets the next title
shot and then he got fucking jock gray.
I don't know what's next.
But you can't beat Kamozi.
He'd already beaten the
nest for a title shot.
There's so many fucking killers
at one 85 85 what fucks sakes?
It's so stacked.
Frankie's Donald,
a lot of spinning back
kicks in this fight.
It's crazy.
Your eyes kicking more than usual to,
well I expected that I that would be
a rye would have like if he had an
advantage it would be in a kicking but
apparently Mark Henry thought that to
Tony Man.
Mark Henry writes novels on
his fighters notes and shit.
There's a nice leg kick I got.
Ain't just pulls that thing out so quickly
and easily as the second time you're,
I had like a little play on a single Ooh,
nice left hook.
Right Frankie retract.
I love Frankie.
So this is a very good fight though.
This is a very religious man.
This isn't like the Cub Swanson fight,
which is just a Frankie Edgar show.
This is a good fight and hope bro.
This is the to the highest level
athletes we have in the UFC.
Frankie Edgar's footwork,
he's so consistent.
He just,
he doesn't waver.
He does the same shit.
He doesn't slow down,
never slows down.
Saint Pace for five and never stands
right in front of you is constantly moved.
Only fight.
He stood in front of me.
Where was the gray Maynard
fight and his coach,
when he comes back to
the corner market goes,
what the fuck did I tell you not do?
What the fuck did we talk about my bat?
And it goes out there and beats the breaks
off and move that to the first round
you like,
how is he even going to fight?
And he came back and won.
The second round isn't saying that heroic
slam and then everybody goes crazy.
There's certain fights that they
really need to stop in between rounds.
And if you looked at the beating the gray
Maynard put on him in the first round,
you would go,
man,
I don't know if he's
gonna be able to make it.
I agree.
But then like look at Machida
versus Rockhold like did,
they could have easily stopped
that fight in between rounds.
They wanted to,
the wool they should have.
They didn't even fucking
put his mouthpiece in.
I know everyone thinks
that Machida was tapping,
verbally tapping,
but he's saying,
I don't have my mouthpiece.
He's trying to get a break
and get the mouthpiece.
Granted he was getting his,
he was getting crushed.
He got,
he got hit in the temple.
He didn't know where it was.
So he got beat up.
Yeah.
That one.
Elbow to elbow.
Yeah.
Luke.
I mean he landed a lot
of ground and pound,
but that one should go at the
end of the round was so loud.
It was like boom.
Like you could hear it like
coconut style one 85 man,
there's not,
there's not a better division.
So fun right now.
You're right.
I think you're right.
Between Shaka Ray,
Luke Rocco,
nice takedown.
Frankie Edgar.
Yeah.
Jocker a yacht.
Rock hold.
Why man feet towards hard Belfort.
Why men and valproate?
Man,
man,
I'm Vito has some very fucking
sophisticated striking as
one of the reasons why.
That's an interesting fight.
Wildcard striking for sure.
If that shit lands are going to sleep.
Yeah.
Ice.
His striking s very sophisticated.
Very tricky.
He's so explosive too.
But will he be though?
That's the thing that's post TRT.
He looks good now.
Have you seen him a little bit in it?
The ride loco photography?
Yeah.
Well,
Ryan said,
you know the photography is obviously
him in the middle of punching,
but he said he looks good.
He lost a little weight for sure.
But I've seen,
I've seen a lot of the video footage
of him sparring a in one of the Nicky
Holt's can videos use him
spar in the background.
He looks fucking good dude.
This is the thing though,
man.
As good as we think he looks,
if you're a guy who's
been on TRT or whatever,
it testosterone your entire career,
now you're off of it and you're fighting
the baddest one 85 on the planet.
Where's your mental state at?
How are you going to go?
That fight went to the second round and
you've landed that spinning heel kick
and you've landed that left hand
and he's not going anywhere.
That's a good point.
It's a real good point.
Yeah.
The real could point.
Where's he going to be at mentally?
Yep.
That's the difference.
Cause Chris Weidman,
Chris Weidman said he uh,
got his blood checked
and testosterone is low.
He's like,
fuck it.
I feel fine.
Say like we me man.
Well,
his testosterone was low,
but I guarantee you a lot of
that is due to hard training.
Hundred percent hard training
just jacks your levels.
You know?
If someone says like,
oh,
I got my levels tested
and they're really low.
Okay,
how often we training?
How often did you train the week?
When did you test?
Yeah,
when you're in folk,
like remember when DC and Jon
Jones both tested like super low?
Yeah,
I do.
What do you think about that?
Because a lot of people said that that
was so low that it was indication or
indicative rather have
them doing something.
Yeah,
because,
well,
I don't know enough about it,
but I ran all the experts stuff.
Well,
whoever they interviewed and they
said for them to be that low,
there would have to be some sort of abuse,
right,
of,
yeah,
but I don't believe that.
I don't think they know
because they both tested.
It was low testosterone
to epitestosterone ratio,
which is the opposite of
knowing someone took steroids.
It's low is the opposite of that,
but we don't know where they
started because DC's older,
he's been wrestling all his life.
Jonathan competing all his life.
So before camp,
where were they at?
We don't know.
For them to test it.
Maybe that's normal for them because
they've been compete all the life.
So to jump at those
accusations is fucking crazy.
I think it's this training camp.
It's like we'll do,
we know like what a really fucking hard
ass training camp does to testosterone
levels.
Is it been like,
is it consistent?
Is it provable?
I mean,
is is a,
is there a baseline that they measured
before he went into camp and then in the
middle of camp,
if you just test him randomly
in the middle of the camp,
you're just getting
whatever he is right now.
We don't really know.
Yeah.
We don't know what's causing it.
You don't know how they were sleeping.
I mean,
that was a stressful fucking leader.
You know,
a lot of time.
A lot of shit.
Yeah,
lots of things.
Fight press conference.
If you take a guy like
you test Herschel Walker,
I bet his fucking levels are naturally
really high and you tested them randomly.
People are like,
oh dude,
he's on Shit.
No,
he's just a freak.
You don't know what this level that
epitestosterone a testosterone ratios.
Even if you're a freak,
there's like a natural level
that you never get over.
True.
That's how like when you see a guy like
who has like a 10 to one testosterone to
advertise Chaucer and
he has to be on onsite,
but they allow you like a two to one,
three to one.
I think four to one.
Nevada you six to once
you still out sex abuse.
Do you see the new rules?
Not what are the new Nevada test sponsor?
Steroids.
Three year suspension.
Oh,
well that's serious.
Three or suspect.
If you test for diuretics or weed,
what?
Three years for years for weed.
Wow.
That's what we're going to lose.
He sure.
Jamie,
can you bring that up?
I say you're not sure.
I'm positive.
I just read it three years for weed.
Pretty sure.
Oh No,
I don't.
I don't think never moving
away from shit like that.
Yeah,
but they changed it that a
sudden they changed that.
No,
no.
Nevada changed the requirements
as far as like how,
what's positive and what's not like what,
how,
what level the metabolites have to be.
They essentially don't
want people fighting.
Hi.
Ooh,
that was a Nice Jab I Frankie now.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure man.
Okay.
This is a fifth round already.
Fuck man.
How'd that happen?
You this first offense,
18 months suspension.
That's for muscle.
Relax,
sleep aids,
opiates,
cannabis,
cannabis.
That's 18 months.
Ah,
second offense.
30 to 40% of your purse.
Third offense.
You said,
didn't you say three years?
I did.
You wrong,
son will.
Well you were right for third offense.
If it's the third offense and a fine.
How about a fine of 75%
of the fighters purse.
Why don't you steal money from him?
Didn't the Guy Fight?
Why are you stealing money from him?
Cause he was on one weed.
Diuretic time.
Two Years Prank.
He takes him down.
Look at this.
Cocaine,
two years.
Damn.
How good is your rock ramble?
Three years.
Good left hook.
Their first offense.
Steroids?
Yeah.
Three years.
First six months.
75 up to 75% of the fighters purse.
Wow.
First offense,
three years.
Second offense,
48 months suspension.
All Mike,
if you run from the test,
48 months.
This my thing though,
so avoiding
36 months.
How many years?
First three years.
So like a guy like Alistair Overeem,
right?
He's been caught.
If he tests positive we get,
does it start now?
Like he gets caught?
Is it 36 very good points.
If he gets caught now,
is it 48 or is it lifetime?
Lifetime suspension?
Fine of 100% if you run
for the second time.
Well,
I'm just like,
so what are they going to do with
Vandelay then because Vandelay there,
there's like a big court case that's
going on with him where he's saying this
wasn't in place.
Right,
exactly.
They were so hoping they were going
to catch Floyd Mayweather on steroids.
75% of 120 million.
Yeah.
Right.
No Shit.
Built a new Vegas.
What'd you guys think of that fight,
by the way?
I didn't rush you.
I enjoyed it.
Me Too.
I'm one of the rare people.
You and I are one of the
rare people that enjoyed it.
Everybody that I know.
Oh Shit.
Frankie almost fell.
Everybody that I know that saw
it thought it was boring as fuck.
I didn't make it up.
A few people loved it.
Loved it.
I enjoyed it.
It's a fucking match.
You watch it again from start to finish.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I'd love to see.
I don't think you,
I'm not going to pay a Hundo.
I'll,
I usually stream that shit hung on my DVR.
I might watch it.
I'd like watching Floyd's movements.
We too,
man.
He's just so God damn slick
and that's the best way to box.
The best way to box is he that guy beat
the game 48 fights and oh and he's fine.
Oh,
and 500 million in the bank.
He ones hoodwinked us
to David conney ticket.
Dave Chappelle was so fucking funny.
He was at the comedy store and he
said that when he was at the fight,
Whitney Cummings yelled out,
I love that girl.
She yelled out in the middle of fight.
Floyd Mayweather beats women.
Dave Chappelle goes men to bitch into,
he said it in the fucking audience.
Fell out,
fell out two bits.
The
way he say he's laughing and they
might had a cigarette in his hand,
and men too.
What's wrong with Whitney?
Which doing well,
she's empowered woman,
you know,
once a letter,
but he knows what they already know.
Well,
you came in support them at the fight
that you pay for a ticket or somebody
bought it for either way much.
Floyd's Paki I don't even
know if it really happened.
That's it.
There you go.
Five rounds,
two minutes y'all.
You can't trust these judges
and 100% I'll look at Frankie.
You're actually,
it's pretty sad.
100% powerful.
Mark Henry,
Ricardo,
Meda.
God dammit,
you should honey.
Get you into that Batman.
I never really lost that much off.
Hence this sets up.
Give me one.
Fuck.
It gets back to sons.
This sets up an opportunity
though for a new,
completely new,
a fresh start.
Fights next week.
Yes.
Yeah.
Vegas.
We're going to be their son.
I'm in Connecticut hosted
Espn Sports Center.
Breaking down the fights.
You got to go to Connecticut,
Connecticut,
Bristol.
Ooh,
that's where do you want a
Anthony Johnson and Cormier?
He got DC.
Wow,
that's a good bet.
That's a great bet.
That's a good bet to take it.
What do you think of that?
We think of that.
What about Weidman?
Belfour
I got Weidman.
I got white men.
Someone who's going to be
gangster and take feed.
Tour.
What?
Hey,
what about,
what about Travis Browne?
Andre last dog Brown.
I follow both of them.
I beat one of them.
What?
Who Do you want?
Travis fucking Brown.
So you want our laps and
I see what you're doing.
You're catching onto
this honey take scheme.
The next week's card man is so stacked.
If you go over about that
one for a little bit,
think about that one thing
about DC rumble of course,
and you'll check the odds,
but it's all good,
but isn't isn't a rumble
like in China or something?
No,
he's back.
He was in town for a while,
right?
Yeah,
he was doing some seminars.
I'm going to try it.
I don't know.
That's a tough one.
Look at this fucking car,
dude.
Here's the fight card.
That joy Benevidez and
Morag has a good fight.
Fuck yeah,
it is Mick desk.
No love.
No,
right.
Well it's just because they
carry the car to just so stack.
It's also those guys suck at Social
Media Dotson versus Zach Makowsky.
No one's talking about that.
That's a great fucking fight.
The good fight too.
That's a great fucking fights.
Too many heavy hitters were.
We're not talking about it.
Ooh,
Frankie one.
How about your Ryan crazy.
How about your Ryan Hall
versus Hofeld and a towel?
That's a good fucking fight.
The good fight.
That's one that PP boy.
Uriah Hall.
Did we shake hands?
Yeah,
we did remember you were like pulling
away and I grabbed your hand and shook it.
I shake hands.
I remember that.
We didn't shake hands I thought
and the double or nothing.
I thought you doubles or nothing.
I think you double it.
Nothing for sure.
Definitely double check.
Sorry.
Frankie Edgar.
Thank you though.
I was stressed.
Yeah.
This some next week's
cardies is fucking insane.
Crazy stack.
It is a really good card.
Do you guys seen the jinx yet and HBO?
We talked about this already.
I wonder if there's more others.
More fights.
Oh ma'am.
Piles at the bottom.
Guilt.
Then we see that Kim Berkman.
It's a good fight bro and bro Rose,
this is dope.
Yeah,
it's going to be awesome.
Roses.
A little superstar man.
She,
she had a lost that finale,
but she's going to be a star.
Don Young Kim versus Berkman.
No one's talking about that.
That's a great fight.
But rose doesn't want to fight.
Johana why raw?
Johan is a savage.
I thought you were saying
she like turned it down now.
No.
Was trying to fight that girl
in that White Polo fighter.
She turned off by that.
I mean maybe she just saying she
don't want a piece of it right now.
Right.
Probably most certainly would find him.
Doug let her get one window.
Honor is,
she's bad ass.
She's cursed.
Strikings nasty.
Yeah.
She's just so crisp.
How's Frankie Conor McGregor breakdown?
That's a really good fucking question
because we've never seen Conor McGregor
getting taken down,
taken down and a guy quicker.
Right.
I've seen a guy quicker than him.
You know who really would
be interesting is Mendez,
Chad Mendez versus Conor McGregor
would be very fucking interesting.
His Chad Mendez can shut the lights out.
Oh,
he has the most power that the lights out
when he hit llamas in llamas was like,
oh,
what was that all about?
I'm alumnus.
He was like bank.
I was queasy.
He's a fucking stud man.
He's a super athlete and a stud.
Oh well it was the,
for sure if there's something I
don't give a fuck about its baseball.
Yeah.
As soon as that came on,
I'm my shut this off.
Look at that terrible
logo there with that.
Who came up?
Multi colored Marlin.
What marketing asshole came up with that.
Where are the Marlins?
The fish that you don't even eat
was trying to um,
sponsor the UFC so I wouldn't talk shit.
How come?
Why aren't they in mind?
We'll see.
It might be in the works.
We don't know.
Yeah,
I'll be scared.
homey.com
there's a fight companions over.
I'm going back to sleep.
I'm proud of,
you know,
falling asleep.
I did.
I did fall the second in
between the fourth and fifth.
You zoned out for a little while.
I went,
boom.
I said Shinzen
nobody's looking.
I looked over at Aubrey and my kid,
he's zoned out,
but I wouldn't know.
Nobody noticed.
Right.
Okay,
cool.
I did go out.
We've got up here.
We got up here at seven o'clock in the
morning and did a four was almost four
hours,
three and a half hour fight companion.
Damn.
Damn good.
We talked about two fights
and team.
That's one thing.
Like in the beginning when
we first started doing these,
people get pitched.
You guys ready?
If you're talking about the fights now,
they never do that.
You,
they've given up.
I'll fuck these guys.
They understand.
Yeah.
David's given up.
All right.
Well,
uh,
we love doing these folks,
so,
uh,
thanks for all the love out there.
Anybody got anything to plug?
Eddie Bravo 10th planet J j.com.
I'll go to youtube and
watch the silent epidemic.
What does that,
it'll trip you out on big Pharma.
There's a lot of big Pharma
documentaries out there.
Person plugs.
He's going in.
It was right here.
She said,
no,
no.
Check it out.
Some
serious helicopters.
I wouldn't be saying it
if it wasn't important.
So foes foes youtube.
It's free.
Hour and a half.
It'll fucking spirits.
He on dragons hour that
half got Dale farm.
A baby.
Big Pharma.
I don't have enough time.
What is that jacket,
man?
This is from a company called reception.
They're working on that close.
I liked that.
I like that.
It's like a Jaguar.
It's like a Jaguar on
Dennis Rodman I think,
or something like that.
It is dance around him.
His buddy.
Yeah,
I'm on it.com oh,
and and it,
uh,
warrior poet podcast,
the Onnit podcast.
Check out that fighter
and the kid episode.
We did.
That shit was sick.
Oh yeah.
Powerful fighter.
And the kid ubi forest coming Saturday,
August 15th,
Orpheum theater,
downtown La.
Oh,
good googly Moodley Ebi back in business.
The last one was fucking awesome dude.
He enjoyed the shit out of it.
Did you see it?
Yeah,
dude,
that that is the best way
to do submission grappling.
I was a little like,
I was a little curious like
how is this going to look?
It's the best idea that
anyone has ever come up with.
I love it.
I was dope.
Huge fan and so that's August
15th Saturday live at the Orpheum.
If I'm in town for sure I'll be there.
Blocked up date off man.
Um,
Saturday night I'll go lock it.
You fucks a hook.
You up man.
Fighter and the kid podcast.
Brendan shop on Twitter fighter and the
kid podcasts you haven't listened is
fucking hilarious.
It's one of the best
podcasts in the country.
It really is.
You guys have such a great dynamic
because Brian so fucking silly.
Calling him a year is pretty silly
to the two of you guys together.
That's fun.
Shirts dropped this Wednesday.
The final,
the kid shop.com chicken had teas
and master Kim Tiger tank tops.
Yeah.
You got to get one of
these chicken had social.
All right.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen.
The next one of these.
We'll do.
Fuck,
when is the next one
these were going to do?
What do we got coming up or upcoming?
Some tough for now it's coming up,
right?
Let me see.
Let me look at the schedule
of upcoming events.
Let's see what we got here.
Um,
you guys watching the
ultimate fighter with a,
Ooh,
Tiago Alva Carlos condit.
When is that?
May 30th fuck it.
I'm out of town.
Fucking shit.
That's a good fight to
conduit and Tiago Ailey.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
Maybe with Dan Henderson.
Tim Boetsch.
June six you guys in town for that?
I'll make sure I am.
I think that might work.
Dot might work.
June six might be the next one.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen.
That's it.
You fuckers.
See you soon.
Bye.
Okay,
real radio.
I tried to go to sleep.
What is it?
$5?
Yeah.
Well a GT three r that's a race card.
That's not a real car.
They're making it available.
Holy Fuck.
How much horsepower?
506 speed transmission.
Wait a minute,
cause everything else is
a six speed transmission.
Hold on.
So that means it's a
manual versus six weeks,
not a road car.
Dude.
Those ours,
they used to be called Rs.
Rs.
That's the race.
That's a real racing,
but you can get the gt
three s that orange one,
what is it?
The Gt three you don't talk about,
it's like yours,
but then it's race.